taking it out and for that you're going
to get some real treats today starting
off with one of Tony's long time friends
Paul beam a University of Washington
it's it's just wonderful to be here and
celebrate Tony it's been uh amazing and
um so when I think think about Tony uh
inspiration is definitely the word that
comes to mind so uh that's uh just Tony
has been
so so much of an inspiration for ever so
many things for me uh so anyway that's
what I'm going to talk about
um
so we shared Steve Cook as an advisor
but it actually took us nearly four
years to me
so uh
I at stock 1991
I was at a lunch table with Stephen Bell
and Tony
and he told me about this upcoming paper
that he had with with Tony Tony was
wasn't there and Aleister urquhart that
had produced these uh uh explicitol
principle bounds for constant circuits
and extended and improving it on paper
by eye type with I Delta zero bounds I
had no idea what that actually meant uh
because I was really in awe I had
actually spent a lot of time trying to
read that paper by itaught and
um and had been complete I had actually
been stuck there was a paper five years
earlier on connectivity small distance
connectivity that I had spent a bunch of
time starting when I was a postdoc
trying to read and I gotten part of the
way and then I had gotten stuff but
anyway I found this particular paper
like completely incomprehensible despite
the trying multiple times just I I
thought I knew something about switching
limit and things and I uh anyway so
um so when I asked Stephen for more he
promised to send the paper but begged
off on more details and said that I
really need to meet and talk with Coney
and I think he tried to connect it but I
don't actually remember seeing you at
the conference at all because he you
were it was in New Orleans
you were there and he was saying well
you've got to meet Tony but but just it
was like on day two or three and we
didn't end up we didn't end up meeting
at all so uh but uh so uh fast forward
so actually we were there at that
conference with with uh Ann and my
daughter Catherine was a it was a fun
time she just learned to crawl the first
night we were there uh in the hotel room
wonderful wonderful food with uh her
falling asleep on my lap in New Orleans
anyway it was a wonderful time but
anyway so we uh she was just under one
and we arranged so she'd get a chance to
spend time with uh uh her grandparents
in Toronto and it was really going to be
great so I would be able to be in
Toronto I could actually go to U of T to
work uh and uh so that's how we could
justify you know the extended time in
the summer in some sense
um so it ended up being just a truly
momentous summer so with this paper in
Hannah it's Stephen had sent me a copy I
finally
felt I was starting to understand things
it was uh really excited to meet Tony
and learn more when I arrived Tony was
away Steve Cook was in Prague
however Russell and paliatsu who hadn't
I I mean I'd seen it at this but I
hadn't really previously met was there
and I think Jeff Edmonds introduced us
who kind of they were hanging out in the
area just in front of uh Steve's office
and began talking about connectivity and
switching limos and Russell and I
particularly were talking about you know
what I could understand what I
understood and I taught his earlier
paper
um so we uh we worked for a bit the and
I was really focused on connectivity but
the connectivity part didn't work at all
but things were seeming promising that
there was something but we really at
least I didn't really understand what
was going on
um but after a Tony arrives and I
finally met Tony you know Tony explained
the framework and there was a lot of
back and forth going through the ideas
and it was wasn't actually that long but
before we were excitedly celebrating
together
uh
so yes as you heard last night there
were some hiccups along the way a little
afterwards but we anyway we were we were
we were happy pigeons
uh so anyway so that was the start and
um somehow I mean for me it really has
you know that was a start that was
something that was really life-changing
and somehow just things seemed to click
and by far more of my work has been with
Tony than with anybody else
um and we could you know we were in
different parts you know I was in
Seattle Tony was in Toronto in San Diego
and Pittsburgh and Arizona back to
Toronto sometimes at is anyway because
we would only see each other maybe a
couple two or three maybe four short
times a year with different time zones
we emailed constantly so in 1993-94 I
had my first sabbatical in Toronto so
you know nearby family Tony was a
postdoc at UCSD
I spent more time emailing with Tony
than I did with talking with anybody at
Toronto actually for that year
um and basically after that we
periodically you know there was email
but we periodically had to have these
long phone conversations and account you
know we we talk and you know that phone
conversation that was the start of you
know would be the start of a new project
and you know back email again but it was
that was kind of you know those
conversations were really in uh just a
huge inspiration and uh I went and
looked so I I used to
sort my mail between 1991 and 2005. I
count there are over 2 600 email
messages from Tony I don't have the
record of my messages to Tony from that
time period because I didn't save sent
mail but this was this is what it was
like
yeah I should have I did occasionally
anyway it was nice yes so uh anyway so
here are some of the papers that we we
worked on together uh you know in in
kind of uh kind of sequence and you know
we it varies there's even some some work
on actual you know practical systems for
component catching random things that we
ended up working component caching
together oh stabbing planes uh yeah
sorry about the name uh
I seem to work I think I came up with
that name but Noah was kind of
disparaging of the name yesterday so
so anyway but we didn't always have uh
the best of uh you know most exciting
range of titles so I did the word thing
for for all of our papers and this kind
of what it was what I came up with uh
anyway so I there's so much to talk
about and I look at the emails some of
these were were overlapping like it was
like particularly some of the earlier
ones there would be multiple things at
once and so messages on on different
papers were because so much was
happening uh particularly early on
anyway so
um so this is uh was really
um
just
you know anyway it's just been amazing
working with Tony talking with Tony
um and uh
um you've really been inspirational for
me you you really I mean you always have
the eyes on the prize the big questions
right you're never willing to settle for
superficial understanding like Tony has
this way of
saying well I don't really understand
something when she understands something
at the level that lots of the rest of us
understand things
but not at the level that she really
really wants to understand things and
this is just uh you know
I can look at them you know I did a
little look at some of these messages
and some of them well yeah but
there would be you know but we really
need to you know go further go deeper
isn't there another better way to think
about something and you are always ready
to like challenge assumptions and just
have this amazing ability to make
connections between different things
that you've been thinking about other
people have been thinking about uh that
that you've heard about and just brought
together it's really and most of all in
a lot of ways
personal research everything you just
make everybody around you just better
um
so uh
so
speaking of inspiration
I I thought I'd I'd talk a little bit
about some uh Recent research with uh
Sachin uh that was uh inspired by Tony
but not with Tony uh uh we we can always
work on that uh
so um
we had this uh paper on uh Lova scriber
and Beyond uh in the mid 2000s and we
approved a very specialized kind of
lifting uh with and gates to uh
uh multi-party communication complexity
and I know at the you know at the time
again Tony uh
well Tony realized that there was so
much more than this and
um
you uh
oh no
uh and Tony and just an absolutely
amazing collection of of grad students
and and co-authors have done you know
produced this phenomenal range of queer
to communication uh lifting results and
again speaking of of being in awe uh I I
uh you know we can we can uh you know uh
uh can all uh sing the the song for that
uh Russell uh wrote the lyrics to on on
Monday uh to think about all the
different ways uh that uh
uh uh that this work has changed changed
the field
um so I actually I don't know that
anybody has technically you know talked
technical things about lifting so I'll
do a little bit
um so in general
um so a number of these uh results the
first results almost always uh talk
about this index Gadget
so for for a lifting so
um I realized I don't actually have a
picture of this composition but anyway
uh so uh you have some function and you
have a a gadget uh called the index
Gadget where Alice has a pointer X and
Bob has a long string Y and the goal is
to Output the bit of Y pointed to by X
and so the general idea I can't believe
I left off the picture let me let me
actually draw it
for like the the one or or two people uh
watching online who may not have seen
this uh so you're plugging in you've got
your function Z z12 ZN and
you have the inputs
to the the new function is a function of
uh bits
um
X X1 and y1 are a vector X of inputs X
and Y and that's uh the the the gadget
so
um and the goal is to show that
um the
communication of this problem this
combined problem is large if the
communication if the decision tree uh
complexity of f is large
all right so
um so the typical
um and Tony
um
has conjectured
that constant size index gadgets are
enough trying to change my mind yes I
understand you might have changed your
mind I know you can do but
yeah so anyway
well
it's okay but it hey
we wanted to try to prove something on
this so that's that was our inspiration
uh
so uh yeah we yes
um
and so how do these query to
communication lifting theorems work so
this is what I mean by that picture is
what I mean by f composed with G where G
is the index Gadget and this is the
decision tree complexity of F and that's
the communication complexity of G but
we're since we're dealing with constant
so anyway so the general Paradigm for
these proofs
is to design uh and this General
Paradigm actually goes uh back to work
uh by uh Roz and Mackenzie and Pierce uh
great uh cares here as well uh is to say
that if you have a uh a protocol
from f
uh for f composed with G you can get a
decision tree for f where you might not
have to you you know you could even save
the communication complexity of g in it
for this purpose for a purpose today G's
only a constant number of bits so we
might as well just think of this as one
so anyway so the input is a protocol
that solves F composed with G and the
output is going to be a decision tree
for f
and so here's the picture we've got our
protocol Pi solving F composed with G
and we want to produce a decision tree
so what we go we'll look at
um this what's going on in the protocol
until we get a point where we've got too
much input information about some pair
so we query that uh uh
that input to f
because we've got too much information
about what's at the bottom so that tells
us too much about Z potentially
uh and then
the decision tree so we have to branch
on both of those possibilities
and then we figure out some more in the
in the in the protocol communication
protocol get too much information about
another uh input pair
and we query that and so on and then at
the bottom when let's say the the
function produces uh output uh elf in
the in the protocol tree
the decision tree output cell and very
importantly not in this picture this
also works for relations like the claw
search problem which
um was you've heard uh uh something
about uh a lot about earlier uh in the
program
so uh so that's the simulation and
um
so in general when maintains uh some
simulation and variance so since there's
a communication problem there's a set of
inputs which is the vector of x's and a
set of or a subset of the set of x's
Vector x's and a set y of that are of
inputs that are currently consistent in
the protocol
there's a set of fixed coordinates where
the decision trees has queried the
answers for all of those uh fixed
coordinates and you've maintained the
invariant that all of these pairs of
inputs are consistent with that uh set
of Z valves
there's a uh the key thing
in order to be able to continue the
simulation is we need something which is
a disperser property the simulation must
be able to produce all possible future
query answers on the remaining
coordinates
one of the ones you haven't looked at
and maintaining these invariants
requires you to keep some sort of nice
structure on X cross uh cos Y and
periodically you're gonna you're adding
new coordinates querying news the eyes
to keep the structure nice and I've
described the deterministic version for
randomized algorithm you need a stronger
extractor-like property that these are
are
um uh
yeah essentially equally likely
so anyway that's the
um that's the general framework and
um so what does it mean to be nice what
is the the structure on X cross y uh
that's nice
um the um the original one and Rose
McKenzie had average degree which is
known to be limited to linear size
gadgets
um and I'm not going to Define them here
exactly but there's deficiency
um which is how many how many fewer
inputs do you have than are possible or
Min entropy or Min entropy rate but
anyway any with this the current best
gadget sizes of are let's say that the
number of bits for the Y player is like
n log n uh in this paper from my itcs uh
2022 with Ian uh and uh and Tony so uh
Goods introducing us uh and it's based
on an improved uh on the improved
sunflower limit
um now as as uh you know
even reducing this m to poly login for
index would lead to breakthrough results
um but
um again uh well Elisa Tony's always
looking for the ambitious uh thing so
constant size gadgets uh uh should be
the uh uh you know what we should be
aiming for
um and actually in the the paper
um that um
there was a conjecture that
um
if you were named larger fixed constant
has good uh disperser property uh for
any sets of Bob's inputs with small
deficiency in other words close the size
of these sets is close to the maximum
possible and this is where uh sagin and
I were uh inspired to uh think about the
question uh and
um uh was a a really nice collaboration
during the the pandemic
um and the first thing we realized
is that for somewhat silly reasons in
some sense all zero blocks the above
conjecture can't be true either using
small deficiency or large minentropy
which are the two other existing things
if that's all you use about the uh about
the sets X and Y uh then you can't get
this now of course M lesson login is a
big gap from n log n but it's also true
for the inner product function where we
can prove this for something I don't
know 5 10 20 log in I'm not quite sure
so the same thing holds we can't get the
size of inner product gadgets if all
you're going to use is deficiency or
um or
um or even
um large men entropy which is actually
what is used to prove the the lower
Bound for the inner product is the is
the large mean entrepreneur so that
that's the that was the first thing
and
well maybe the conjecture
um you know this specific version isn't
the right thing but what other condition
you know yeah
okay so here's
um so in a random input you've got M
blocks
right
the um
in M blocks how they got probability uh
one over you know if they're smaller
than log n you would expect about a
they're sorry they're in little n blocks
Emma you're going to expect
a reasonable chunk of all zero blocks in
uh in the input Y and there's nothing
about the inputs X that will ever get
you uh both values
yeah could we fix this by restricting in
advance to why being like an error
correcting code
so there are various things like that
that are those that kind of thing is
exactly the the the sort of thing that
that might be able so I'm more
optimistic maybe than Tony now but
something like that balance error
correcting code something of this sort
does seem possible of course we're
talking a constant number of bits but we
can pick big constants so I think it's
not out of the question
would be any of these would be great yes
absolutely we tried we weren't able to
do that
so at some point we we even thought we
could prove something uh uh you know
above but didn't work out
um so we weren't quite sure what that
could be so the next thing we did was
say first to try a restricted class of
protocols so maybe we could prove it
prove it for a restricted class of
protocols that would give us some ideas
um
and
this is
um the other uh uh part of uh of our
work is that for restricted protocols
lifting with constant size index gadgets
as possible and this is the class that
for whatever reason we decided to try so
in our restricted protocols there's no
limit on what Alice can send but Bob who
has the the long string y can only
commute compute communicate parodies
events input so we've got a star to say
that Alice can send anything and uh
that's not multiplication but it's um
and parodies for for y so that's the uh
that's the restricted class of protocols
and
um it turns out we can indeed prove even
with you know Alice has two bits and Bob
has four
um that with uh that you can actually
get a um a full lifting from decision
tree complexity to communication
complexity
um and then we realized actually that if
we made Alice send bits we could
actually do some nice things to balance
the size and similar ideas would uh do
uh things for decision tree complexity
and decision tree size and there's a
version for relations that gives proof
complexity lifting from tree res uh to
tree res parody I mean
uh Dimitri's circle of an uh and it's
accent had shown specific examples uh
based on actually one of the well
pigeonole and and the
um Titan lifting uh that I that I
mentioned that's in the the lowest
scriber and Beyond uh but this gives a a
general family and then has uh suha was
mentioning uh last week when uh sajin
was uh presenting this at Banff we
discovered that this was actually
independently known so if you were in
the uh talk last week so
um uh talked about this result and the
proofs are are very very similar the the
the key ideas are are very very similar
uh so I'm just going to give a little
bit of the the base oh yes so here's the
overview of the simulation we've got
some invariance we're going to make sure
Y is an F on Subspace of of the set of
index vectors and the co-dimension of
that space is going to be at most the
number of bits sent so far and the
simulation maintains a set of dependent
coordinates y i j and all other
coordinates are are free and can take
all possible values
the set X has high Min entropy rate and
this means that no value has two larger
projections so there's our definition of
highman entropy rate uh and the other
thing no coordinate that's outside of
the set eye where we've settled
everything points to a dependent
coordinate of of Y
so that's those are the invariants that
we maintain
um the actual proof uh again if you're
in sir house talk last week in almost
almost guess what's going on so here we
have a node where Bob sends some parity
um and let's suppose you know there's a
zero one possibility so let's suppose we
we're going to go along the One path the
simulation here actually maybe the other
path is even possible but in this case
the simulation actually has a choice but
anyway so we've we add the equation
rewrite this so we're going along this
path y11 is is one plus uh y34 and we
Mark we choose this arbitrarily we Mark
that as a dependent coordinate
uh then uh we update X to remove that
dependent coordinate so we add this
constraint
um and then Bob maybe sends some other
thing and notice why one one is also in
that one again we have possibility Let's
Pretend We're going to follow the zero
Branch so we're going to rewrite this in
a way so y11 is dependent already so
we're not going to choose that as a
variable so we pick y four three we put
that on the other side again we Mark
make sure X doesn't uh a doesn't point
there
um now this may lose bin entropy rate
down here on the X's
um
and
what happens if Alice speaks again you
know
zero or one we typically you pick the
side that's more popular if it's
parodies will you get a choice
um uh you just restrict to the set of of
inputs it may lose Min entropy rate uh
so we got two things how do we handle it
well we go to to Tony uh uh and uh we
use the density restoration method of
ghost potassium Watson uh which actually
is the part that makes uh the queries uh
and uh we do the same when it of course
when we're in the in the previous step
if it happened to lose man entropy right
there and that's basically it that's
that's essentially the whole proof yep
uh what happens in the day case uh well
you you will notice we've been
maintaining dependent coordinates and
now we decide and we got two paths that
come together we've got completely
different set of dependent coordinates
and we have no idea we've about how to
proceed because we've been basically
keeping track of the entire history
through through this process and it's a
little unclear how you would or not a
little more than a little unclear how
you would combine these uh so
yeah for those of you who are who aren't
paying attention
um what about dependent coordinates is
is basically uh the open question here
which is dag sorry uh dagleg so daglike
uh lifting protocols for parity right
that would we could handle that that
would solve that would give us resilient
lower bounds that would be amazing
um so
um there are you know what are these
other conditions I think this is I think
this is actually really right we just we
have to get our mindset to things like
you know error correcting codes as
Russell said or some sort of something
that will do this and maybe other
restricted classes protocols will give
us new ideas I'm we we tried that I'm
I'm not so sure but anyway this is like
for the for the general case of course
the daglite case would be good yeah
please like analyze the protocols and
use like other symmetric functions or
well uh we so thresh majority threshold
who is the next thing we tried
and it gets pretty tough the parodies
interact in really nice ways a
collection of majority constraints does
is a very complicated object so
um but we we definitely tried some of
that I'm not saying it can't work that
was in fact in such in slides at itcs he
actually mentioned mentioned that but I
uh uh as as one of the possible uh
directions uh for for doing this yeah
that you can
wire these sets nice
it it could be so the question is
couldn't is it because we have a Metroid
uh
that's uh that certainly possible I mean
the other thing that's nice I mean one
thing that's nice we get to pick what
the basis is and of course the Matrix
you do get to move bases around and you
know that might that's another uh kind
of thing I'm not quite sure on on the
restrictions itself but but it if you
actually work through it's
um
it's so straightforward in some sense
how the work the proof Works
um I I hesitate to uh to say that it's
only Metroid properties that we're using
so uh because I just haven't uh thought
so much uh so anyway uh uh so uh finally
Tony you've been completely
inspirational for for me for my career
hey in my life
um most of on all of these things most
of all you've been a true friend thank
you and happy birthday
[Applause]
thank you so much
yeah
I don't even know if I want this on film
no this might Patrol out there but
um
I wonder if some of those ideas could be
used here so the the
um anyways this is just a throw out so
so I just said this the three-term
three-term airplane progression like
they have these two Notions one that's
what they want and then the other one
they want to morph it to the Subspace
like
marriage
the tools that I don't think have been
explored well yeah I mean it's certainly
that's that's super exciting exciting
work I I
um it's something I want to understand
better I don't have a clue whether it
has it connects but but it's it's it's
yeah yeah it's definitely definitely
very exciting
yeah sure other questions yeah
so while the time for a lifting primer
[Laughter]
a lifting practice
oh well it's there's
Tony has already written most of that
lifting with prior well uh or Mika uh uh
but anyway so yes it probably is time
for a lifting primer for sure you just
volunteered to write it yeah yeah
yeah
are there any questions
I uh
so I am also I'm also kind of optimist
it's exactly the same one as the
sunflower example actually it's like a
block wise a set system where the you
know you just take basically every set
which is like a full X yeah and why you
just like take half of them yeah
absolutely so
um but yeah it seems like there's a lot
you could do inside that you know stick
to air charging code or whatnot if
that's not true do you think that we
could use that counter example to uh
exhibit do you think it's so natural do
you think it could relate to some
specific communication problem lifted
communication problem that actually can
get gains when you put the uh size too
low
so so if it's not a general lifting
thing and it failed somehow could we get
a communication like would that uh when
we
could we convert that to figuring out
what the hard problem is for for lifting
that would actually I mean right this is
I mean basically this win-win thing uh I
I think is a a great strategy for
working on problems you know to try to
solve you know uh so yeah uh yeah I'm
only asking because the your your
counter example yeah it's it's for silly
reasons quote unquote but it's also so
it's like you could imagine it arising
in practice like so simple right yeah
more generally we don't really have bad
examples for lifting yeah right right
yeah right yeah
uh okay other questions
sorry it might sound
all right well let's thank Paul again
thank you